Welcome to the Beginner's Guide
for Armored Core six.
By the end of this video,
you'll understand what it means
to play Armored Core at a higher level.
You'll be faster at the controls.
You'll know how
to put together a powerful AC,
and you'll be able to quickly read
and adapt to any situation.
Feel free to skip ahead to a section
that you're more interested in.
But for now,
let's get started at the beginning.
First, let's get to grips
with the controls.
This guide will assume that you're
using the default type A
control assignment, with a controller,
but mouse and keyboard can be
an effective means of control as well.
If you're playing on PC,
be sure to open up the settings menu
and scroll down to input device settings
where you can ensure that
your button prompts are being properly
displayed for the input you're using.
And while you're here in the settings,
I also like to go into the camera
settings and turn camera speed to ten.
That's because turning quickly to face
enemies is very important
in Armored Core,
as you'll soon learn.
So you've just crash landed on Rubicon
and your AC has taken damage.
It's AP, which stands for Armor
Points, can be viewed here
to instantly repair your AC.
Press up on the d-pad.
This consumes a repair charge, seen here
which instantly heals
your AC for a flat 4000 AP.
The bar underneath shows the delay
before you can repair your AC again.
And it's important to note
that you can't repair your AC
while firing your weaponry.
Be sure to keep your AC
topped up on health,
especially if you think an enemy
is capable of
extremely damaging attacks,
which many of them are.
If you think enemies might be nearby,
you can press down on the d-pad
to scan your environment.
Again, The bar below shows how often you can
use this,
so there’s no enemies nearby.
But if there was, you could fire at them
with any of one of your four weapon slots.
Right now we're equipped
with an assault rifle in our right hand,
a missile launcher on our right shoulder,
and a laser blade on our left arm.
Your back triggers activate your left and
right arm weapons, and your front bumpers
activate your left and right back weapons.
Note how your total ammunition
depletes in the bottom right of the screen
and how your current magazine capacity
is affected here around your lock-on.
Let's get moving.
So when at a standstill, your glide
boosters are disengaged and you can walk.
However, you'll often want to press circle
or B to manually engage your boosters
while grounded, as that is a superior
form of movement, especially in combat.
Note that these glide boosters
automatically toggle
on when you quick boost as well.
The indicator for glide boosting is seen
here. We’ll need to ascend
to reach our objective marker,
which is shown here.
Pressing X or A while grounded
will cause you to jump with your leg part
and after that jump holding X or A
will cause you to ascend
with your boosters.
Ascending requires energy
which is being depleted here.
Energy consumption
is paused while descending,
and your energy recovers really rapidly
while you're grounded.
If you fully deplete your energy bar,
it will go red
and energy will not recover
for a short duration.
So you should generally try
to avoid fully depleting
your energy bar
if possible, in the heat of combat.
Keep an ear out for warning
sounds as well.
The warning for loss of energy is
just one sound
that can give you crucial information.
Now let's fight some enemies
In this game,
Lock on is automatic when you're in range.
And the enemy closest
to the center of your screen
will be locked onto by moving the camera.
You can target other enemies
by aligning them more closely
with the center of your screen.
This method of targeting
is particularly useful when taking out
multiple enemies, as you might want some
to have priority over others.
Our assault rifle is on our right arm,
so we fire it with R2 and take them out.
However, in many cases you might prefer
a more automatic hard lock,
and for this you can enable target assist
by pressing R3
In this mode,
four crescents appear here and now.
When an enemy is in your sights,
you'll be hard locked onto them.
In this state, your tracking accuracy
is slightly reduced,
so your shots might not hit your target
as effectively
as if you didn't have target Assist on.
However, this way
your enemy is kept in your sights
at all times and you don't need
to touch the thumbstick at all.
Really.
This is particularly useful when you're
fighting against a single difficult enemy,
especially if that enemy
has dangerous attacks
that require you to focus on
dodging and flight instead.
One thing to note in the center
of our lock on is this yellow crescent.
That's your missile marker.
And the number represents
how many missiles
are chambered
and ready to be fired at this enemy.
Only try and fire your missiles once
the yellow bar has fully loaded like this.
When the number appears,
you're fully locked on.
And while you can fire the missiles before
this, they won't track very well at all.
Our missiles are attached
to our right back.
So the marker appears in the top right,
and we can press R1 to fire them.
But if you're against multiple enemies,
you might not want to fire
all your missiles at just one enemy.
Instead, what you can do
is hold down the fire button like this.
This will acquire a multi lock and split
your missiles evenly to all enemies
within your field of view.
Lastly, our starter build is equipped
with a laser blade on its left hand.
This means we can tap L2 to swing it
and it will boost us
towards any locked enemy
as far as our energy will allow.
All melee weapons can have their input
held for a charge attack and
this one in particular can be swung twice
if L2 is pressed in succession.
After attacks,
the blade also overheats, meaning
it can't be used for a short
period of time.
For every encounter,
you should be finding a way
to maximize efficient use of every weapon
you have equipped.
With this build,
we use multi lock missiles to initiate.
We fire the assault rifle
when we're in range
and we use the blade whenever we spy
a safe opening.
So we've just finished a fight
and our assault rifle is low on ammo.
Many weapons only reload automatically
when their magazines are empty.
So you should make a habit of manually
reloading
to ensure that you are topped up
between fights.
Manual reloads can be done by holding down
triangle or Y
and tapping the fire button for the weapon
that you want to reload.
Let's head down to the city.
This is called an assault boost.
You perform this by pressing L3
and it propels
you towards wherever you're aiming.
Pull back on the left stick
to cancel the assault boost,
like this.
or tap the ascend button X or A
to cancel your boost
while maintaining your forward momentum.
Like this.
Assault boosts are by far
the most efficient way to move around
the map.
However, where this ability really
excels is in combat.
Assault boost is just an excellent tool
for closing the gap towards enemies.
And if you have
the energy to spare,
you can even dodge left or right during it
by tapping the left
analog stick like this.
But what makes assault boost
truly powerful is that you can attack
as you assault boost
and many attacks done during this time
deal increased impact damage
meaning they'll be more effective
at breaking enemy guards.
What's more, impact you receive during
this time is also lessened
meaning you can assault boost
into many enemies with reckless abandon.
So let's show this off against the next
two enemies who have shields.
By combining our assault boost
with a blade attack,
we can absolutely obliterate them.
But let's keep the second one
alive for now.
See the two meters above the enemy?
This one shows the enemy's health,
and the second one shows
the enemy’s ACS Strain.
ACS strain builds up orange like this
whenever you attack.
And when the bar fills fully,
the enemy's guard is broken.
In this state of ACS
overload, enemies take direct damage,
which means any attack
you unleash in this moment
is far more damaging to the enemy's
health.
Naturally, enemies can do impact damage
to you as well,
and your ACS strain will build up here
above your energy bar.
If an enemy attack breaks your guard,
your AC will pause like this
and you'll take additional damage as well
to ensure that this doesn't happen
You should try and maneuver for extended
periods where you don't take any damage.
After a few seconds of no damage,
ACS strain will diminish
and this is where
the environment often comes in handy.
It's something you can use
to block attacks, giving you
time to reduce ACS strain
and often to reload as well.
But notice how my assault rifle
isn't doing much impact damage
to this shielded enemy.
That's because some weapons are better
at building up impacts than others.
If I use my explosive missiles
or my blade,
for example, then I can easily break
the guard of the target.
The first
true test of your skills
will be this
the AH12-HC helicopter.
In this fight, you'll have to use
everything you've learned.
Plus another skill as well.
The quick boost by tapping square or X,
you'll be able to dash
for additional avoidance.
It's worth noting that an Armored Core
there are no invincibility frames,
however, So
think of Quick Boost as a way to quickly
get distance away from an enemy's attack
rather than an ability
that you use to dodge an enemy's attack.
Quick boost is particularly useful,
while target assist is enabled
because your thumb is free to tap
the boost button and I highly recommend
putting target assist
on while you're fighting most boss battles
because it's here
that you're going to have to pay special
attention to enemy movements and attacks.
So to recap in this fight, I'm
going to try and accomplish a few things.
I'm going to use target assist to hard
lock onto the enemy,
and I'm going to constantly fire
my assault rifle and missiles
pretty much as soon as they're available.
I'm also going to do my best to assault
boost in and use my blade on cooldown.
This is my main damage dealer in this fight.
And when I return to the ground
to recover energy,
I'm going to do my best
to stay close to the enemy.
I'm safe when I'm close and I'm safe
when I'm underneath the enemy.
But if the enemy has distance on me,
I'm going to use the environment
to my advantage.
This is particularly useful
when you see warning signs like this,
or if you just need a moment to reload
or repair or reposition.
Coming up with a battle plan for bosses
can really work wonders in this game.
So with this,
I should just naturally come out on top.
Let's put this plan to the test.
After the mission is complete,
you'll obtain your reward.
COAM credits,
minus the ammunition and repair costs
that were incurred
during your successful mission attempt.
After each mission, you'll return to this.
The garage.
Here, players can have some downtime and
prepare for success in future missions.
Right now we've just finished Mission one
and the part shop
isn't open to us, so let's
check out the Sortie menu instead.
Here you can and should do a few things.
First, head to the training simulator.
Here you can defeat some basic enemies
and learn some invaluable lessons
about the game.
If you ever need to review these lessons,
then you can always display
the license menu in the garage
by pressing triangle or Y.
Then navigate down to the tip screen.
By completing training, you'll often be
rewarded with powerful new parts for your AC.
So I highly recommend
completing new training missions
as soon as they become available.
And do your best to read
all the information as well.
If you want to quickly test out
any of these new parts,
then you can press the right bumper
during assembly to initiate an AC test.
Or you can just head down into the AC test
area from your Sortie menu.
Once you're here, press the pause button.
It's in this menu that you can spawn
a variety of enemies to practice against
without having to worry about incurring
costs from going out on missions.
You can also switch out parts in assembly
and they'll appear here on your
AC immediately.
You can even restock your ammunition
and heal up if needed.
AC Testing is an incredible tool.
However, in many cases
it might be beneficial for you
to just go out on actual missions instead
and test out your weapons in the field
for this purpose.
There's the replay missions option.
If you're confident in your abilities,
then by replaying missions,
you stand to gain additional credits
or a higher rank as well.
And what's more, some missions have
optional objectives or parts within them.
So go out there, get some more practice,
earn some more credits
and see what you can find.
But when you feel ready,
you can sortie onto your next mission
and progress in the game.
Oftentimes, you'll have a choice
of mission and you might want to read
the mission descriptions and evaluate
how many credits are on offer as well.
Because you'll need those credits
soon enough, because
after mission 2, the parts
shop becomes available
here, you can buy new parts
or sell your old parts.
And as you complete
more missions, new parts
will quickly become available in the shop.
Your available credits can be seen here.
The price of parts can be seen
here, and buying parts
will show you a reduction
of your available funds.
But the most important takeaway is this.
Don't be afraid of buying new parts
and experimenting here.
It's absolutely essential
that you get a feel for different parts.
And most importantly,
parts can always be sold back to the shop
for the same price you purchased them at.
So nothing is ever really lost
in this shopping process.
Soon we'll go over the process
of constructing an AC,
but first I want to say that
there's one more way to acquire AC parts,
and that's through a process
called log hunt.
After Mission three, you'll be able
to participate in this log hunt program.
This means that every time you defeat
an enemy in a mission that is marked
with this battle log icon, you'll gain
progress towards your next Hunter rank,
at which point
all-mind will reward you with new parts.
Battle logs
can either be bronze, silver, gold
or platinum,
with each being worth more than the last.
So keep a lookout
for these markers in your missions,
and if you do miss one, consider
replaying that mission to claim it.
Battle log status will be shown in your
replay mission screen here and here.
So if it ever says pending
or the icon is grayed out.
Replay the mission.
Find that battle log
and complete the mission to claim it.
Before long, you should start feeling
a lot more confident in your piloting.
For me, this happened around Mission five,
which was a short mission
that required that I take out
a Defang student pilot.
This mission was over fast.
It wasn't too hard
and it netted me a lot of credits.
So I replayed this over
and over for a while.
These frantic
AC fights are great practice, so
if you're struggling, I highly recommend
you replay this mission.
Challenge yourself to destroy the enemy.
AC as quickly as possible.
Claim your credits.
Go out and buy a new part to test and
then go back in and take out the enemy.
AC Again.
If you get an S rank,
you are doing really well in this mission.
Before long, you'll be feeling much
more confident with the flow of the game
and after a few more missions
you'll have enough credits to refine your
AC into something that you want to pilot.
And that process of refining a build
is a huge part
of the joy in Armored Core.
There's a special sort of satisfaction
that comes with
putting together builds to perfectly suit
your needs.
So let's head into AC design
and break down that process.
As we go through the process of AC design,
remember, you'll rarely find parts
that are objectively
better than others in every way.
Instead, parts are balanced
by being strong
in some areas and weaker in others.
If a stat is blue,
that means that stat is an improvement
over the stat of the part that you
currently have equipped in that slot.
If it's red,
then that stat is a downgrade.
It's up to you to decide what stats
you value the most for your build,
and that's what makes this build process
so fun and personal.
12 parts
make up an AC assembly for unit parts
four frame parts, three inner parts,
and an expansion slot.
When you arrive in the AC design screen,
you can cycle through these 12 categories
horizontally with your left
and right bumpers, and in the column below
you'll be able to select the specific part
that you'd like to equip
from that category.
Each part has a name, seen here.
A weapon class
like handgun or bazooka seen here,
and a written description
that tells you a bit about the weapon.
Descriptions are often great at describing
what's unique about a weapon at a glance
without you needing to go deeper
into stats to figure it out.
For example, this bazooka description
tells us
that it deals heavy impact damage
And if we go back into the part’s
specs section,
we can confirm that this number is in blue
and has an upwards arrow
signifying that this weapon indeed
does do a lot more impact damage
than the assault rifle
we currently have equipped.
What we currently have equipped
is actually all the way down at the lower
end of the impact scale
as shown by this little gray marker.
These five specs
are the simplified specs of each part.
If you want to look at each part's
detailed specs, you can press
triangle or Y for an expanded list.
And if you need any help
figuring out what all these specs do,
then you can press the Help
button, select contextual help
and then cycle through for a
more detailed description of each spec.
If this expanded start screen is
overwhelming to you, don't worry too much.
Beginners can absolutely get by
with just the simplified start screen.
So for now,
let's go back to that simplified view.
Almost all parts have two specs in common.
They all have a weight
and they all have an EN load.
The combined weight and EN load
total of all your currently equipped parts
can be seen on the right here, in a section
that shows your AC’s combined spec total.
Again,
you can toggle an expanded view of this
if you like, but the simplified version
is more than enough for now.
And even then,
what you'll really want to keep an eye on
the most is your current load
and your current EN load.
This little gray marker shows
what your current load is at. This red
or blue bar shows
how the currently selected part
will affect your current load
and the gray marker with an arrow
shows the maximum load your AC can handle.
We'll talk about weight
limit a little bit later, but for now,
just remember that you generally
do not want to ever go beyond this arrowed marker.
Weight and EN load are the two
limiting factors
that help to offset the strength of parts.
If a part is heavier
with a high EN load, that means the part
will generally be more powerful.
But it also means that it will be
more difficult for your AC to carry it.
If a part is light with a low EN load,
then the part might be somewhat weaker,
but your AC will more easily
be able to equip it.
The power and utility of each part
are expressed by the main
specs situated above their weight
and EN load.
For weapons, these specs are typically attack
power, impact, and total rounds.
Attack power determines the damage
dealing performance of each projectile.
Essentially, it's how much damage
you can do to an enemy's health bar
impact determines the damage that you do
to an enemy's ACS train.
The higher your impact,
the more easily you'll be able
to stagger an enemy
and open them up to direct damage.
Total rounds are simply the total amount
of ammunition that you're
bringing into a mission with that weapon.
This can be relevant
as if you run out of ammunition.
You'll no longer be able to fire
the weapon.
Instead, the depleted weapon
will be purged from your AC and
you'll be forced to fight with your fists
instead, which can still work.
In addition to these specs, weapon parts
also have
some icons that tell you
more about the weapon at a glance.
For example, the fourth slot will tell you
if this weapon
affects a particular part of the enemy
craft.
The napalm launcher, for example,
can inflict a status effect
that will cause the enemy to be staggered
more easily.
The third icon represents
whether a weapon is single shot or whether
it needs to be reloaded, or if it doesn't
need to be reloaded and will overheat.
Instead, if a weapon can overheat,
the progress towards overheat can be seen
accumulating here around your lock
on, if possible, keep an eye on the spart
and space out your shots
to allow your weapon to cool.
This will avoid putting your weapon
into an overheat state.
If a weapon is in an overheat state,
then you can't fire it
and you just have to wait for it
to cool down.
And the second icon corresponds to
the type of weapon seen up here as well.
And the first icon tells you
the damage type of the weapon.
So there are three types of damage
that your weapons can deal in.
Armor, of course,
six kinetic energy and explosive.
First, let's talk kinetic damage.
This is damage done
with physical projectiles.
Most common in weapons like the assault
rifle, the machine gun, or shotguns.
Kinetic weapons are typically better
at close or medium range.
They typically fire quite fast
and they generally also have a
higher direct hit adjustment
spec on average, which means
they're a great option for dealing damage
while an enemy is staggered.
The second type of damage is energy
damage.
This is further split into three
more types laser plasma and pulse.
Laser weapons fire, straight blue beams.
Plasma weapons are purple and create
an AOE explosion on impact.
and pulse weaponry
Fire bubble beams that are great at
wearing down pulse defenses.
On average, though, energy weapons
fire slowly and are typically better
at long range with high attack power,
but low impact.
So use these to capitalize on an enemy's
broken guard.
Don't always rely on them to break it.
The third type of damage is explosive
damage
typically dealt by bazookas,
grenades, and missiles.
Explosive projectiles often deal
the same amount of damage
regardless of range and often create
an AOP explosion to boot.
What's more, weapons with explosive damage
have high impact and attack power specs.
However, this is offset
by slow firing rates and a lot of recoil.
They're a great tool to have
for breaking open enemy guards though,
and most builds are well served by having
at least one explosive weapon equipped.
So those are the three types of damage.
But naturally,
there are three types of defense as well.
If you're stuck on a boss or enemies,
consider what their defensive stats
or weaknesses might be and experiment
with different types of weapons.
Before I move on from weapons,
I'd like to mention
melee weapons and pulse shields as well.
Melee weapons can only be equipped
to the left arm slot
and pulse shields can only be equipped
to the left back slot.
We've talked about melee weapons already,
but note that they have a main spec
called Consecutive Hits, which lets
you know how many times
the melee weapon can strike
with repeated taps of L2.
As for pulse shields, I probably wouldn't
recommend them for a beginner
as using them properly requires
quite a bit of timing and finesse.
That said, if you do want to equip
one note that their main specs are
damage mitigation, impact dampening,
and deployment range.
damage mitigation is essentially the percentage of damage
that the shield will block, while it’s active.
Impacts dampening is a mechanic
that determines your initial guard window.
When shields are deployed,
there's this little brief moment
where you can block more incoming damage.
So blocks should be timed ideally
to correspond with incoming attacks.
But be aware that this will overheat
your shield more quickly
so you can't just repeatedly tap
it too many times.
Lastly, deployment range is a value
that determines the size of your shield.
Next,
we have the full frame parts of the AC.
Let's start with the head.
Head parts are unique
in that they determine the power
and range of your scan function,
but beyond that,
their main specs are AP, attitude
stability, and system recovery.
AP are your armor points, your health basically.
Attitude stability contributes
towards the maximum amount of stagger damage
that you can absorb.
So a higher value means
it'll be harder for an enemy to strain
your attitude control system
and knock you off balance.
And finally, system recovery determines
how fast you will recover
from status effects inflicted by things
like fire or electricity.
Next, the core part.
This is the part
that will typically contribute
the most AP and attitude to your build.
It's also typically the heaviest uniquely,
though the core part also has a stat
called generator Output Adjust,
which is a value that determines
how effective your generator parts
will be at fulfilling your energy needs.
But we'll get into energy
and generators a little bit later.
And then there are the arms.
Arms.
Give AP, of course,
But the unique specs determine
your arm load limits
and your level of firearm specialization.
Armload limits can come into play
when your arms are carrying extremely
heavy weaponry.
If you're holding weapons
that are too heavy,
you'll get this warning on the right,
which means you'll need to equip
lighter weaponry or choose arms
with a heavier load limit.
Finally, there's firearm specialization,
which improves
target tracking performance.
If you find your shots are missing,
your target a lot.
Consider selecting armor parts
that have higher firearm specialization.
Finally, and most importantly,
we have the leg parts.
And this might just be the most important
part in your AC’s entire assembly.
Let me explain.
So leg parts contribute
AP and attitude stability
like all your other frame parts, but
they unique in that they are responsible
for carrying the combined
weight of everything else on your AC.
Thus, the most defining spec
is this their load limit.
This value changes
this arrowed marker over here
which determines the maximum weight
you can carry.
And it's the marker that you never want
to exceed when building your AC.
Generally, the closer you can get your AC
to this load limit, the better.
Though I will point out that
the further back you go from this marker,
the lighter your AC will be
and it will grant a slight
increase to your boost speed as a result.
But the really unique thing about
legs is up here, and that's their type.
There are four types of leg:
bipedal, reverse jointed, quadruped legs
and tank treads
Each come in heavy or light variants.
But it's the type of leg you choose
that plays a massive part
in how your AC will control.
Biped legs are your jack of all trades.
They're certainly a safe
bet for new players
and they're all you have access to
at the beginning of the game.
Before long, though,
you'll unlock these reverse joints.
Reverse joints are still bipedal legs,
but they're unique in that
they have unparalleled
jumping abilities in gameplay.
This means that your jump will propel you
further into the air, and it also means
that your quick boost will fling you
further to the side while you're grounded.
Consider reverse joints
if you need to be more airborne
or more evasive,
but note that you'll generally be more
easy to knock off balance
if you're ever hit with these legs.
One of the drawbacks to all bipedal legs
is that they don't absorb
recoil whenever you fire
heavy weaponry or burst weaponry.
Notice how I'm pausing in the air
when I fire these sorts of weapons?
That's because of my biped legs.
And while it's absolutely still viable
to use weapons like these with biped legs,
this pause can definitely get you
destroyed, If you fire at the wrong moment.
However, that recoil is not as impactful
with the other two classes of leg
which are quadruped and tank treads.
Quadruped and tank treads
can absorb recoil from heavy or burst
weaponry, allowing you to fire them
while you're moving.
Though it's worth noting that quads do
slow down slightly
while firing, while tanks are uninhibited.
Completely.
This ability to hover is what sets
quadrupeds apart from tank treads.
Once you're airborne, all you need to do
is press the jump button again
with X or A to hover in the air.
Pressing jump a third time
will drop you out of this mode.
While you're in it, you can still dodge
and fire your weaponry, though
you are slow
and you'll need to return to the ground
to make substantial energy gains.
The biggest advantage
of flying like this is for maintaining
additional range from enemies.
And just in the fact that it often gives
you a straight line of sight at enemies
without any environmental clutter
getting in your way.
It's also amazing against sudden enemies
that don't have attacks
that can reach you.
So consider keeping a set of quadruped
legs on hand in case you need them.
They can be a really powerful situational
tool to have at your disposal
thanks to their hover ability.
With tank treads,
On the other hand, your booster part
is actually removed from your
AC assembly entirely as the tank treads
come with their own in-built boosters.
With some exceptions, flight
isn't typically a strong point of most
tank treads.
Tank treads are more about grounded
movement and operating.
These really feels like
driving a wheeled vehicle
where the direction
you're facing really matters.
That said, you can still quick boost
while grounded, which will instantly
change your direction if needed and propel
you into a temporary drift state.
Slower treads will also benefit
from making frequent
use of the assault boost ability
to cover distance.
At the end of the day,
though, tank treads are really designed
to carry an enormous load
and it's generally
a good idea to load your tank
with the most devastating weaponry
and the most resilient frame parts
you can carry.
The next three parts of your AC are its
inside parts, which consist of the booster.
The FCS and the generator. Booster parts
are most defined by their thrust,
their upward thrust and their quick boost
thrust specs.
Your basic thrust value is what determines
your default speed while gliding and flying.
An AC with a high default
speed will naturally be quite avoidant
without you needing
to take any particularly evasive maneuvers
which you might consider useful.
If you want to focus on things
other than dodging.
Your upward
thrust is exactly what it sounds like.
This value determines how powerful
your upward trajectory will be.
Being in the air can help you
to avoid explosions on the ground,
and it also allows you
to get a better angle on your enemies.
So consider this spec
especially relevant for sudden encounters.
And then there's your quick boost thrust,
which determines
how fast your thrust will be
when your quick boost is activated.
This expanded view actually
shows a lot more quick boost values
that you should also consider,
but generally you should only select
for quick boost thrust.
If you find yourself
facing an enemy that you think requires
a lot of manual dodging.
Another important stat is hidden
in the expanded stat screen,
and that's quick
boost reload ideal weight spec.
If your total weight rises above this
value, your AC will have its quick boosts.
reload time progressively penalized
Quick boosts and flight require energy.
So naturally
we should talk about the generator next
because it's this part that determines
the nature of your energy bar.
The generators
main specs are its EN capacity,
its EN recharge and its supply recovery.
EN capacity simply determines the maximum
amount of energy in your energy bar.
An AC with a higher
EN capacity will be able to perform
more actions before this bar is depleted.
However, it's also important
to take into account your EN recharge rate
as this determines
how quickly your energy will recover.
An AC with a higher recharge
rate will be able to spend
less time
recovering and more time doing actions.
Then there's supply recovery,
which determines
how quickly your generator will recover.
If you fully deplete your energy bar.
Ideally, you'll never fully
deplete your energy bar,
but sometimes that's necessary
to avoid attacks and high supply
recovery will get you back to the action
without being punished too hard.
Finally, unlike every other part,
the generator doesn't
actually have an EN load.
It has EN output.
So it's the generator
that's responsible for supporting the
EN load of the rest of your system.
Your total EN load can be seen here
on the right, and the gray marker
represents the combined EN load
of all your currently equipped parts.
That red or blue bar determines
how that EN load
will change depending on the part
you have selected.
And the arrowed marker is your maximum
EN capacity
as defined by your generators
and output stat.
Basically,
if you're exceeding your maximum EN load,
you'll see red here
and that means you either need to switch
to more energy efficient parts or choose
a generator with a higher EN output.
The last part we need to go over
is the FCS part,
which is the biggest contributor
to your aiming accuracy.
You might have noticed
when you lock onto enemies,
your aim is actually determined
by this little reticle within the lock on.
When it's red, you're considered in range
and your non homing projectiles
should hit their mark.
Keyword there, though, is should because
this little reticle isn't always on point.
Sometimes it will waver,
sometimes it will lag behind.
And it's this behavior
that is determined by the FCS part.
FCS parts have three main specs:
their close range assist
medium range assist and long range assist.
Close range assist determines
how good your reticle will be
at tracking enemies
within the 130 meter range.
Medium range determines
how good tracking will be between 130
and 260 meters and long range determines
how good tracking will be beyond 260
meters.
Pay special attention to distance markers
during combat
and try to stay within the optimal range
for your FCS and your weapon.
Missile tracking is separate from the FCS,
but the FCS does determine
how fast you can acquire a missile lock
and how fast your lock capabilities are.
So this is a factor
to consider for your build.
And that's the basics
of everything in your assembly.
And if it sounds like a lot,
well, you're not wrong, but rest assured
that it will start to make sense
as you jump in and experiment with things.
So let's try
and put together a unique build now.
And while yours might be different
from this build, I'll show you the order
that I generally prefer
to put things together.
One of the most straightforward ways
to get started with a build
is to first decide on which FCS
you should use.
That's
because this forces you to decide early
whether you want to build something
for close, medium or long range,
or whether you want something
that's just decent at every range.
Having an idea in mind helps
when getting started.
So let's aim for a close range
build and choose a close range part.
The focus I want to go for
is this: the FCS-G2 / P10SLT
It has good performance
at close to medium range
and it comes with the added
benefit of quick missile lock time,
which is great
as we'll be using missiles as well.
So next, let's choose a good close
range, arm weapon to suit our FCS.
Expanded specs screens
reveal optimal ranges
for firing each weapon
and the one for the MG-014 Ludlow
reveals
that it's a great close range option.
So let's equip two of them.
One for each arm.
What we’re using now is called a double trigger
build.
Meaning
you'll be dual firing these machine guns
at once with both of your triggers.
The Ludlow's
description also specifically calls out
that it's great in dual trigger builds.
This is why reading descriptions
can be so useful.
As mentioned before, the description
on our FCS revealed
that it's principally designed
to reduce missile lock time,
which means that our missiles
will also be a very effective tool.
So let's equip two sets of those
on our back and all of a sudden we have
a build that is deadly at close range
and with long range missiles as well.
Looking good.
The next decision I like to make is legs.
You have to ask
what would suit a close range build
while you could go light
and avoid taking damage entirely.
But as a beginner, you're
probably going to get hit a lot anyway, so
might as well go with something heavy.
For now, let's go with the Tian Qiang
bipedal legs. As these
give us a high load limit to play with
while we select our other parts.
Having a high load limit makes it
so much easier to put together an AC.
I can confidently select heavier parts now
and by intentionally selecting
for heavy weights.
I can kind of just trust that
the other specs
will naturally be quite good.
Another way to quickly put together
a build is to buy parts
that just exist within a family of parts.
Most parts will have keywords like VP
or Melander
as well as a company logo
that can help you
ascertain the family of parts
that they exist within.
For example, buying all of Schneider's
Nachtreiher
parts will make your build
very fast and great in the air.
Whereas buying all of Dafeng's Tian Qiang parts
will naturally make you slower
but very tanky.
So by buying all of the parts in a family,
you can easily
get a good idea of the type of AC
those parts are moving you towards.
And while you're definitely encouraged
to mix and match, buying all the parts in
the family is kind of a guarantee
that they'll work well together,
which might be a welcoming thing
to many beginners.
Because I've replayed Mission
five so many times,
I have over a million credits,
so I'm going to use these
to buy every frame part in Dafeng’s
heavyweight family of parts.
If you don't have enough credits
here, consider
replacing missions
or selling parts that you don't need.
And if you can't afford the same parts
that I'm buying, don't worry.
Consider parts to be a goal to work
towards and just see if you can get by.
In the meantime, next, let's choose
Boosters.
Manually dodging with a quick boost
can be a lot of extra
input for a beginner, so let's just select
for a high thrust stat instead.
This will enable us to move
at a high speed by default
and we should just naturally avoid
a lot of attacks this way.
Luckily, the BST-G2/PO4
is perfect for those needs.
Next, I like to choose a generator.
Now generators can get pretty heavy,
but since we have those high load
bearing legs, we might as well just choose
the heaviest generator we can find.
This generator,
the Ling-Tai, gives us a reduction
in our EN capacity,
but notice it's only a slight reduction
considering the dramatic increase
in our EN recharge and supply recovery.
I'd say this is a very welcome trade off,
so in the end
you should have something like this,
a close range AC with an extremely high
AP and defensive performance.
We're not done
because once you have a build,
you should take a moment to review things.
The most important thing to look at
is your current load.
A good goal
is to try and get as close to your weight
limit as possible without exceeding it.
So if you have a ton of space
free at this final stage,
it means you might want to go back
and put on some heavier parts.
Alternatively,
if you're nowhere near your load limit,
you might want to go back to your leg
selection and choose lighter load bearing
legs as that would confer benefits by
bringing you closer to your weight limit.
All that said, don't worry
too much about being super close
to your weight limit,
even though I have some space here.
I'm happy with that too,
because space means I'll be able
to quickly switch to heavier weapons
if the mission requires it
without changing any of my other parts,
which is really convenient.
Speaking of weight,
consider expanding the stat screen
on your booster here and check
that your total load
doesn't exceed your
ideal weight
spec on your booster by too much.
Again, the more you exceed
this value, the slower
you'll be able to quick boost repeatedly.
Last check your ACS maximum EN load.
Like with weight,
it's important to be under
and as close to your ideal
EN load as possible.
If you feel like you've settled
into a really optimal build,
then it's often a great idea
to head into the AC data screen.
Here you can name your AC
and save this build for future use.
This is a great way to get some personal
attachment to the build that you're using.
And also in a practical sense,
having multiple builds on hand
can help you to quickly adapt
to different situations.
You can also try and copy enemy
AC presets over in this tab
as long as you have all their parts
available.
Finally, consider stockpiling a few back
up parts before you go out into missions.
This will allow you to switch up
your assembly mid mission,
which can be extremely useful.
Me, personally,
I'm going to buy two bazookas
because you never know
when you might need a bazooka or two.
The first mission
that new players are kind of
likely to get stuck on
is this Operation Warp Climber.
So I'm going to use this mission
to show off a few more advanced mechanics.
Our first objective
is to take out the Gatling guns over here.
Now, while objective markers show
you your goal,
you don't always have to take the straight
route to get there.
For example,
if we go straight,
there will have to go through
a battlefield and straight into Gatling
gunfire, which is not the best idea.
So instead, since our build
is a little bit on the slower side,
let's take the scenic route.
The tank is still shooting us,
but by listening for warning signs
and staying in the air to avoid explosions
on the ground, we can reduce
damage taken here.
Next we go over the ramparts,
firing our weaponry on the way.
Assault boost keeps us fast enough
and tanky enough to avoid the snipers
aiming at us.
And by tapping us
end to end my assault boost,
I can maintain momentum and quickly regain
energy on the ground.
By setting up a flanking run.
I can take out the Gatling guns
without having to stop.
Next, listen for warning sounds.
As you go through the city,
your eyes will basically tell you
when you're at risk of getting hit.
We can use the environment for cover
and even use our compass
at the bottom here
to locate any nearby enemies.
There are quite a few enemy
empties in the city, but
directional markers will let you know
where an enemy has fired at you from.
This marker lets me know that
there's one coming up right behind me.
Repair kits heal
A flat 4000 AP.
You should always try to use them
after you've taken
4000 damage to make sure
you get the full benefit from it.
But it's also valuable to stay topped up
so you don't have to heal
in the middle of a fight instead.
Our next objective is the BAUS tetrapod.
It's hidden in a nook under the city.
Let's get to it.
There's the tetrapod.
And because it's a single imposing enemy,
it's probably a good idea
to toggle on our target
lock with R3 before we get started.
When fighting enemies, it's important to
keep in mind your weapons effective range.
This is something that you should try
and memorize in the garage
before heading into battle.
Our weapons effective range is 236 meters.
So we should look at the distance marker
and try to keep that in mind.
Now, normally
our weapon would be effective
at this range,
but against this enemy, it's not.
That's because this enemy
has a very high defense.
Therefore,
our weapon is ricocheting at range.
Remember to keep an eye out for this
ricochet notification while you play.
If it appears,
it means you'll do little to no damage
unless you get within your ideal range,
at which point, attack power is guaranteed
without ricochets.
For this weapon,
our ideal range is 115 meters.
Because my ace is slow
and my weaponry is good in short
bursts, I'm going to use the environment
to my advantage here.
By peeking around this corner.
Whenever my missiles are up,
I can build up ACS strain at range
with no risk.
And when the enemy comes close to me,
that's great because my machine guns
can take it to a breaking point
without it posing any threat.
When playing,
consider your build strengths
and consider the enemy's weaknesses
and come up with a plan.
If that plan doesn't work.
Reassess your build or reassess
your strategy.
That's how you overcome
difficulty in Armored Core.
See the bottom right?
That's where you'll be able to note
that you've unlocked a checkpoint.
We're done here and we can proceed.
But while we're here,
we might as well take out the cannons
that were pestering us on the wall.
These are optional enemies.
But every kill rewards us
with credits in the bottom right.
Therefore, destroying these cannons is
well worth it if we have the time.
Our objective
marker tells us where to go. Now.
But there are often other ways
to your objective as well.
For example, if we take this door
above our objective marker,
we can actually sneak inside
and get an advantageous high position
over our enemies.
There's a marker here that denotes
that they're unaware of us right now.
Damage dealt to these enemies
during this time
will result in higher impact and ACS Strain
The final boss of this mission
is a tough one.
It's the juggernaut.
The juggernaut has armor
that negates all damage from the front.
Note the armor notification here.
However, its sides back
and top are vulnerable.
So a build that has great
generator capacity and high boosts.
A thrust speed will be able to maneuver
in the air and get over the juggernaut
more effectively.
Any build can beat the juggernaut, but
if you're using a build that has to return
to the ground more often,
then you might have a harder time.
But if you fail during this mission,
don't worry.
The game's checkpoints
system will instantly allow you
to restart at difficult encounters.
What's more, if you have the parts,
then you can consider quickly
switching up your build here
by entering assembly.
Remember how I said
my build has some extra load free?
Well, I'm going to make use of that now
and I'm going to equip
two heavy bazookas instead of my machine
guns.
These bazookas deal explosive damage,
which will help me to stagger
the juggernaut much more effectively.
The juggernaut is a slow, large target,
so the usual drawbacks of
using bazookas
don't really come into play here.
Another thing to consider during
this fight is whether you want to use
target assist with R3 or not.
It's true
that yes, target assist is generally great
if we're just facing one singular enemy,
but there are absolutely exceptions
to this rule.
The juggernaut is one of them.
Target
Assist has a few drawbacks in this fight.
For one, it forces you to move at an angle
respective to the enemy.
This is especially concerning if I try
to assault boost towards the juggernaut.
Doing this while locked on means
I'm assault boosting right into its front.
That's not where I want to go.
With target lock disabled, we're able
to move more freely around the enemy.
What's more, our assault boost is free
to be aimed above or
beside the juggernaut, better enabling us
to get around it as an added incentive.
Playing without target
lock actually increases
the tracking strength of your lock on so
our shots will find the target more often
if we don't use target assist.
Consider all of these things
and your overall skill level
when considering whether to use
target lock in your missions.
Shortly after Operation Wall Climber,
two new menus will become available:
the arena and OS tuning
The arena is a ranked simulator
where you can fight enemy AC.
There's no healing or multiple enemies,
just a fair one on one fight.
Here you can climb in the ranks.
And while we can only
fight against F-rank opponents
at this early stage of the game,
more enemies will be unlocked.
As you progress in your missions.
And the arena is absolutely something
you should be clearing
as soon as new AC fights become available.
Not only is this invaluable practice for
some of the hardest fights in the game,
not only are you rewarded with credits
with no repair or ammunition costs,
the most important thing is that you're
also rewarded with a crucial resource.
OST Chips.
OST Chips are a resource
that can be spent on various
categorical upgrades for your AC.
This is done in the OS tuning menu,
and once you're here
you'll be met with a series of upgrades.
Some of the upgrades in these menus
are intended for more experienced players.
For example, few players will ever find
they need to aim manually
or to enter a mission while overburdened.
So be careful not to waste your points
on upgrades that you won't use.
That said, you can recover your spent
OST chips by pressing triangle or Y.
This will cost you 4000 credits
for every OS upgrade you need to undo,
but some upgrades here
will make any player stronger
regardless of their skill level.
While I'd recommend you read through
and consider these yourself,
let's go through each category now
and pick out a few priorities
in terms of system unlocks.
One that I'd absolutely recommend
everyone unlock eventually
is the kick function.
With this enabled,
you'll be able to do a melee slam
at the end of your assault boost
by pressing L3 once again.
This is especially great.
While you're hard
locked onto an enemy with target assist
and it's the perfect capstone to an enemy
who is almost guard broken
because it saves
you having to expend ammunition
on breaking their guard
and it leaves your ammunition
free to capitalize on their broken
guard instead.
Next, let's talk expansions.
Once unlocked, expansions
can be slotted into your AC’s assembly.
And while you can only equip one expansion
at a time,
you can invest into unlocking
multiple charges of each expansion.
However, note that unlocking
multiple expansion charges is expensive
and there's a cooldown period
after using an expansion charge.
By default,
expansions are activated by pressing
L3 and triangle,
or Y, simaltenuously.
However, you can switch these controls
in the game settings here.
Personally,
I prefer type B, which allows activation
with L3 and R3, which is easy to remember.
When your just starting out, It is easy
to forget to use your expansions.
So if you're new to the game,
then I'd actually recommend
that you choose a passive expansion
instead.
For example, this is terminal armor.
Once equipped, it's always active
and will always keep you alive at
1 AP for a few more seconds in a situation
where you would have been destroyed,
this can give you valuable time to heal
or just survive a little longer.
I really can't overstate
how useful passive upgrades
are in an input heavy game
like Armored Core six.
After terminal armor, I'd recommend
getting the early ranks of many
passive upgrades.
You can't go too wrong here,
and by investing in passive upgrades,
you can rest
that your AC is becoming more powerful.
And that concludes the guide.
Thank you for watching.
More Tips
Lore and Secrets about Armored Core six.
Consider subscribing to my channel.
Good luck everybody.
Get to work.